[Music]
for decades europe has implemented
policies for young people helping them
to study
travel find work and yes also to have a
little fun along the way
europe's flagship youth program erasmus
was also one of the first launched in
1987 it gave students the support they
needed to study in another european
country broadening their horizons
learning languages and making friends
in 1996 the idea for the european
voluntary service was born
this would later become the eu
solidarity corps
precursor
[Music]
to recognize the important contributions
made by young people across europe
parliament launched the charlemagne
youth prize in 2008 since then it's been
awarded every year to projects that
promote cooperation and understanding in
europe and beyond
tackling unemployment and creating
opportunities for europe's young people
was the goal of the 2013 youth guarantee
accepted
[Music]
the system the formation of
but work isn't everything in 2014 the
european youth event was born
held at parliament's home in strasbourg
the goal was to celebrate european
citizenship debate ideas and meet
like-minded people
it was clear by 2014 that erasmus was a
roaring success
so successful in fact participants had
even become known as the erasmus
generation
engaged culturally aware and european
when the commission proposed updating
erasmus to include other youth programs
parliament pushed for a wider scope and
more investment
erasmus plus was born
how could young people be encouraged to
explore the diversity of european
cultures that was the goal of discover
eu launched in 2018.
[Music]
000 18 year olds were given inter-rail
passes allowing them to travel the
continent in their first year of
adulthood
the scheme remains hugely popular today
so what about the eu of tomorrow
that's what the conference on the future
of europe is all about
the conversation involves europeans of
all ages and a third of them are under
the age of 25. this time their
conclusions their proposals will be
taken into the conference on the future
of europe from here starts a very
important exercise because these young
people will say what their priorities
are in european policies for the coming
years
[Music]
you